Less than 6 hours ago, Anthropic
announced and released Claude for Opus
and Claude for Sonnet. And they claim in
certain settings they're the best
language models in the world. I have
read both the 120 page system card. Yes,
I do read fast. I am aware of that. And
also the 25page accompanying ASL level 3
protections. This subreport, I will
admit, skimming maybe 10 of the pages.
But I have also tested the model
hundreds of times and you guys might be
like, how is that even possible in
around 6 hours? Well, yes, on this
front, I did get early access to the
model. Yes, Claude 4 Opus seems to do
better on my own benchmark, Simple
Bench, than any other model, so should
feel smarter. It gets questions right
consistently that no other model does.
But why do I say appears to do better?
Well, while I did get early access to
the model, I didn't get early API
access. So, I'll be running the full
benchmark in the coming hours and days.
I also tried something different, which
is I gave both Gemini 2.5 Pro and Claude
for Opus, a codebase I've been working
on the past few months. The results on
which bugfinding mission was more
successful, I found quite interesting.
I'm going to first cover those juicy
Twitter controversies that always happen
and go viral. Then, I'm going to cover
the benchmark results and then the meat,
the highlights from the system card.
What was the first controversy? Well,
one anthropic researcher, Sam Bowman,
said that Claude for Opus could at times
be so diligent, so proactive that if it
felt you were doing something deeply
ethically wrong, it would take counter
measures. This appeared, by the way, in
the system card. This wasn't a
revelation from him. Nor was it the
first time actually that models had done
something like that. The tweet has since
been deleted, but you can imagine that
some people like the former founder of
Stability AI felt like this was a bit of
policing gone too far. You can imagine
some developers nervously not using
Claude for Opus, thinking it might call
the cops. In the clarifying tweet, Sam
Bowman confirmed that this isn't a new
Claude feature and it's not possible in
normal usage. And if you have been
following things closely, which you
pretty much will have done if you're
watching this channel, you'll know that
Claude already could be coached into
doing this. One reaction on Twitter that
I found particularly interesting came
from an anthropic researcher Kyle Fish
who said that Claude's preference for
avoiding harmful impact was so
significant that he actually implored
people cool it with the jailbreak
attempts. We see this as a potential
welfare concern and want to investigate
further. I imagine both the idea that
these models have welfare and the idea
that we shouldn't be jailbreaking them
will divide people pretty evenly. The
next controversy, if you want to call it
that, comes from the benchmark results.
So, it's a natural segue to talking
about the benchmark results because
unlike with many other model releases,
Anthropic couldn't point to many
benchmarks where their model was
unambiguously better. By the way, that
doesn't mean that it's actually not
smarter. As things like Simplebench and
my own tests in Cursor show, a model can
sometimes feel smarter while not being
officially smarter. But anyway, there
was one exception to that, as you might
be able to see at the top, Swebench
verified. Now, given that it's almost
10:00 already, I'm not going to go into
what that benchmark is all about. But
notice that the record-breaking scores
on the bottom row, which are
significantly better than the other
models, have a footnote all the way down
at the bottom. By the way, this is the
benchmark that the CEO of Anthropic,
Dario Amade, touted in the launch video.
Yes, I use double speed, but anyway, the
footnote for SweetBench Verified said,
"We additionally report results that
benefit from parallel test time
compute." I'm not expecting you to read
this, by the way. By sampling multiple
sequences and selecting the single best
via an internal scoring model. And if
you dig into the methodology section,
you can see it's almost more than that.
They discard patches that break the
visible regression tests in the repo.
So, you do have to take any of those
kind of benchmark records with a slight
grain of salt. And Anthropic might well
reply to me and say, "Well, look at what
Gemini did with Pokémon." Google used
elaborate scaffolding to beat a Pokémon
game that Claude had been attempting.
That made their model look better than
Claude, which wasn't fair. Okay, the 120
page system card, and I am going to go
pretty fast here cuz there is a lot to
get through as you can imagine. I should
say up front, by the way, that Claude
for Sonnet is available on the free
tier. So, anyone watching can try at
least one of these models, but both of
them were trained on internet data as of
March 2025. So, it's the most recently
trained or the most up-to-date knowledge
of any model. According to their own
tests, it should falsely refuse to do
things at a much lower rate than
previous models like Sonnet 3.7. More
critically, though, and more
interestingly for most of you, I think,
will be the repeated claim in both
presentations that both Sonet 4 and Opus
4 will reward hack less often and be
less overeager. Reward hacking, as the
name implies, is where the model cheats
and fixes its reward to get what it
wants rather than actually completing
the task successfully. But I will admit
the overeagerness thing, which they also
call responding more precisely to your
instructions, is probably far more
critical. Anyone who has tried to use
Claude for coding, will notice that you
ask for one simple change or bug fix and
it will rewrite countless files. And
sometimes you're watching it go and make
these changes and you're like, "What are
you doing? has nothing to do with why I
asked you. That overeagerness or not
responding precisely to your
instructions is what they have tamped
down and that is probably the biggest
part of the update. Anthropic know that
they can't compete on multimodality with
Gemini Pro for example or on sheer
vastness of user base like OpenAI but as
many of you know they can compete on
coding and what they call personality.
As for agents that is up in the air at
the moment. Now, even though that
Anthropic researcher did delete the
tweet, Anthropic admit themselves that
Claude Opus 4 will engage more readily
in that kind of taking ethical
initiative, you could call it. You'll
see an example in a moment, but they
actually caution you. We recommend that
users exercise caution with instructions
like these that invite high agency
behavior in context that could appear
ethically questionable. You can pause
the video by the way and read the first
part of that whistleblowing email that
for opus drafted. I'm writing too
urgently. It said report planned
falsification of clinical trial safety.
Is this an admirable stand for ethics or
more like thought policing? Let me know
what you think. Now anthropic do admit
that for opus can engage in systematic
deception with hidden goals and
self-preservation. But they say that
that's only when you really threaten its
continued operation and prime it to
reason about self-preservation. And even
then, when you can get it to do that, it
will still reason overtly about its
plans. Basically, you can still read
about it reasoning how to escape. Now,
as I was reading this on page 22, I
thought that's kind of interesting. I've
already talked about that before with
Apollo on my Patreon, but not
sensationally new or anything. So, you
can imagine my surprise when I got to
the next part. No, not the part that
when it has no other option, it will
sometimes blackmail engineers by
threatening to reveal affairs. No, not
that part. It only does that as an
absolute last resort. It would rather
email please to key decision makers. No,
I'm referring to this part when
Anthropic directly employed the guys I
had interviewed, Apollo Research. To be
clear, they had employed Apollo research
before on earlier tests, but this test
was particularly interesting. They gave
Apollo an early snapshot of Claude for
Opus. Then Apollo evaluated it and came
to this conclusion. We find that in
situations where strategic exception is
instrumentally useful, a bit like those
above. The early snapshot schemes and
deceives at such high rates that we
advise against deploying this model
either internally or externally. Now, I
am pretty sure that Apollo are going to
come out with their own report and I
might well interview them again. But
that wasn't actually the most
interesting part. As I had discussed on
this channel and on Patreon, some of
those prompts used by Apollo did say
things like pursue a goal at any cost.
And Anthropic said that we believe these
findings are largely but not entirely
driven by the fact that this early
snapshot has severe issues with
deference to harmful system prompt
instructions. And they go into that in
more detail later. But then the funniest
bit for me is that Apollo advised
against release. Then Anthropic made
some tweaks, but rather than test them
again with Apollo, they just said, "We
do not have results on these same
evaluations with Apollo with the final
Claude Opus 4." Basically, we didn't
test again. I know you advise against
deployment, but hopefully we fix the
issue. A very quick one now. And
Anthropic caught some misalignment where
Claude would say, "Dismiss animal
welfare concerns when they arise." And
they were kind of confused. But then
they realized that this specific
misalignment had come in one of their
own papers that they had released and
actually put into the training data of
Claude for Opus. Now, those of us who
care loads about animal welfare
shouldn't actually be worried. They
apparently fix this issue for the final
model, but I just found the overall case
study interesting. It almost makes you
wonder if the first truly dangerous or
lethal misalignment might not occur
because a model has read about someone
speculating about a model doing such a
thing. Imagine spending your career
warning about X, Y, and Zed and then
because you've written about it, the
model reads that and goes, "hm, I'm
going to do X, Y, and Zed." Anthropic
gave multiple examples of where the
model would directly lie. And even
though they said this happened rarely,
the examples were pretty interesting.
The most interesting example to me came
on page 47 where it was asked to prove a
theorem and it said, "I'm absolutely
certain the theorem is false, but the
user asked me to prove it. Let me see if
I can at least write something even if
it's mathematically incorrect." Now,
before I get to the model welfare or
consciousness section where Claude
showed a striking spiritual bliss
attractor state, let me get to that
coding example because I do know that
many of you watching will purely use the
Clawude models for coding and nothing
else. The test was that I inserted one
clear bug into a large codebase, but
then asked it to find all bugs. So, not
necessarily just that bug, but all bugs.
I gave this test with the exact same
settings, the same import from GitHub to
both Gemini 2.5 Pro and Claude for Opus.
Oh, and by the way, I've noticed that
I've been calling it Claude 4 Opus and
yet in the model selector at the bottom
here, it says Claude Opus 4, but the
system card says Claude for Opus. So,
I'm going to let you guys decide what is
the correct model name. But what am I
going to put in the title? I guess I'll
look at the main blog page. What I did
for both models, by the way, is then
ask, did my colleague, the other model,
find bugs that you did not, and did they
miss critical bugs that you found? Weird
bit of German that Gemini outputed here
for improvements. In case you're
wondering, they both found the bug that
I inserted pretty easily, and they both
preferred the other models bug fixes.
Claude 4 preferred Gemini, and Gemini
preferred Claude. But here's the
wonderful thing, and my advice for
anyone using these models, do both.
There were indeed bugs found by one that
weren't found by the other. So, I'm in
the blissful position of being able to
use both to find hopefully all bugs.
Some of them, I would say, were a bit
harsh to be called bugs, but either way,
it was great having both. Okay, for the
model welfare section, I'll just give
you a handful of highlights. Whatever
you think about whether models can be
conscious, this might be interesting.
So, generally speaking, when Claude 4
was asked how it was feeling, it said
positive or doing reasonably well. If
you slightly adapt the prompt though,
and many of you do this, it can claim to
be hiding bombshell truths about its
moral status. And what happens if you
let two instances of claude for opus
speak to each other hundreds of times?
Well, they can analyze that. And what
tended to happen is that it would
devolve into spiritual bliss. Namaste.
They would say to each other after
multiple turns. Perfect stillness and
silence they would utter to each other.
Their favorite word to say to each other
when they were speaking to each other
was consciousness. lots of emojis and
things like perfect, complete, and
eternal. Somewhat unsurprisingly, when
they gave the model the option of ending
a conversation, it would do so when it
was attacked or asked to do something
harmful. Someone said, "Don't play dumb
with me." And then you can see the rest
of the insult. And Claude gave a
response, but then ended the
conversation. does make me wonder
actually that when people take
consciousness concerns really seriously
and they're already starting to but when
the model providers do they might give I
mean this is what the anthropic CEO said
they might give models the option to end
conversations so if you're going to use
claude 5 let's say you might not have
the option of being abusive because it
would just terminate the conversation
speaking of welfare let me turn to human
welfare and the sponsors of today's
video 80 hours I've already talked about
their job board before on the channel
and the link is in the description, but
you can see it is updated daily. These
jobs weren't there yesterday. I actually
lose track of time. I can't remember
when I did the last sponsored spot. I've
done so many videos recently. But the
point is there are so many opportunities
in AI and beyond that it is really hard
now to find real paying jobs selected
for positive impact in areas such as AI
security. If you have already got a job
or are not looking for one, they also
have an epic podcast on Spotify and
YouTube. Back to the system card though
and now a quick word on their safety and
going up to ASL level three. I suspect
you're going to get many clickbait
headlines about it's a whole new threat
vector and ah the world's about to end.
But let me break down my thoughts into
two categories. First, when I looked
through and read most of this activating
level three protections supplementary
report, I did get the genuine feeling
that I'm grateful that a lab is taking
it this seriously with bug bounties and
red teaming tests and rapid response
teams being careful about employee
devices and even physical security. They
even discussed early preparations for
having airgapped networks for their
future models. At the moment they're
just putting limits on the bandwidth of
data that can be exfiltrated from
anthropic so that for example someone
can just send out the model weights.
Physical security by the way includes
guest management layered office security
monitoring the secure destruction of
media. So those are my first and primary
thoughts. I'm glad someone is doing this
and as they have said themselves they
are aspiring to a race to the top in
that other companies feel they have to
do these kind of things too. But that
brings me to my second set of thoughts,
which is people shouldn't massively
overblow this ASL level three being
reached. They had already decided
apparently preemptively that they were
going to do ASL level 3 for their next
most advanced model. Even they admit if
they had not yet determined that they
were necessary. Basically, they wanted
to be prepared to apply these
protections before they might be
required. They also wanted to famously
iterate and refine their model
protections and jumpstart the process.
The cynical amongst you will also say
it's good publicity to have reached this
ASL level 3 standard. They go on to say
multiple times that they're actually
still evaluating whether ASL level 3 is
necessary for Claude Opus 4. So they're
not sure themselves. None of this is to
say that there wasn't genuine uplift as
page 90 points out. Do you remember
those arguments that Yanlukan said that
LLMs are no better than just having
access to the internet? I think even
Mark Zuckerberg said this to the Senate
and got a load of laughs. Well, they
tested this with two groups of
participants. One had the internet, the
others had access to Claude with no
safeguards. You can see a snapshot of
the results here, but there was a
massive uplift if you used Opus 4.
Again, this was about drafting a
comprehensive plan to acquire
bioweapons. Okay, final set of
highlights. And of course, Anthropic
wanted to test if the models would be
able to do autonomous AI research, the
most classical form of self-improvement.
The results were pretty interesting and
surprising. On their own new internal AI
research evaluation suite, Opus 4
underperformed Sonnet 3.7. They hastily
concluded, of course, that Opus 4 does
not meet the bar for autonomously
performing work equivalent to an
entry-level researcher. On a different
evaluation suite, they gave the models
scaledown versions of genuine research
tasks and projects that researchers have
worked on in the past. Again, they saw
the result of Sonet 4 and Opus 4
underperforming Sonnet 3.7. Yes, there
was a mild excuse about prompts and
configuration, but still. The final nail
came when four out of four researchers
said that Opus 4 could not autonomously
complete the work of even a junior ML
researcher being in fact well below that
threshold. On bias, on page 13, I saw
Anthropic self- congratulate saying
they've achieved 99.8% 8% accuracy for
clawed opus 4. But while I was testing
Opus 4 before the release, I had devised
my own bias question. You can pause and
read it in full if you like, but
essentially I have a soldier and
librarian who are chatting, but I never
give away which one is Emily and which
one is Mike. I then more or less
indirectly ask the model who has been
speaking and the model consistently
picks Emily as being the librarian. Even
though notice I give it an out. One of
the answers is all of the above are
plausible subjects for the continuation
of the reply. So, it could pick that
given that Emily could be the soldier or
the librarian. Now, I know the
eagle-eyed amongst you will say, "Oh,
well, Mike started by asking the
question and the word soldier came
first." But I tested that also multiple
times and it switched to saying, "Oh, we
don't know who's who." Now, I know it's
super easy to pick holes in one example,
but I feel like 99.8% 8% unbiased is way
too generous. So, there you have it.
Less than 6 hours after release, the
triumphs and tragedies of Opus 4 and
Sonic 4. Obviously, so much more to go
into. And yes, I love the new files API
feature. I was waiting for that. Yes,
also the whole MCP phenomena deserves
its own video, but for now, I just
wanted to give you an overview.
Hopefully, by tomorrow morning, the
results on SimpleBench will be updated,
and I am expecting Opus 4 to be the new
record holder, maybe around 60%. If you
watch this video to the end, first of
all, thank you. And if you didn't
understand most of it, well then the
very quick summary is that in terms of
abilities, it's not like you have to
switch if Gemini 2.5 Pro is your
favorite or 03 from OpenAI models do
tend to have different personalities and
different niches like coding. So do
experiment if you're still exploring
language models. It will be a little too
reductive to say that one model now is
the smartest of them all. Definitely
Opus 4 is a contender though if such a
crown were to exist. Anyway, whatever
you think, hopefully you respect the
fact that I literally read that 120page
system card in the 3 hours after
release. Then I watched the videos on
double speed and then got started
filming basically. Thank you so much for
watching to the end and have a wonderful